Oh what is going on YouTube recently a
lot of you have been leaving a lot of
messages in my inbox asking me to talk
about the friendzone oh but what is the
friendzone you asked for those of you
who don't know the friend zone is the
area which a lot of men are put into by
women in which they are trying to go
from friend to lover they're tender well
instead of staying at home a touching
yourself to your pass out I'm here to
help you out with that player but we're
not Kentucky yourself part you know you
do that by your damn self I don't shop
Oh God
well you already know what it is LG
awesome a B let's get that down first
you must ask yourself something are you
even in the friend zone you have to
think for yourself maybe they just don't
like you
Oh some of you dudes out there take any
other kata to the side of learning but
let me tell you something
[ __ ] nothing happen no bro she touched
my shoulder I felt this it was electric
yeah a word she touched your shoulder
that's in dumbass let me tell you
something unless she touched your other
shoulder your Shermantine honey nothing
happened maybe you have some booger that
fell out your crusty ass eyes and she
was just wiping it off fellas you cannot
say that you're the friendzone just
because you're attracted to her it don't
work like that
if attraction was one-sided Scarlett
Johansson I would be in Hawaii right now
writing twin dolphins with twin unicorn
spanking each other with Vaseline and
two straight razors and a box of wine
second stop saying [ __ ] like this if
because I was too good of a friend to us
she feeds me like a bro she sees you as
a brother
let me hear cats for the lonely ghosts
the problem is she don't see you at all
now maybe some of y'all are actually in
the friend zone like there is some type
of attraction but both y'all are kind of
afraid to make a move let me ask you
something you're stupid what the hell
are you waiting for
are you ready for that half naked baby
wings to come out you know with with a
little arrow in the heart to shoot you
in the booty cheeks is that what you
waiting for
is that a sign what's his name Caesar no
Caesar his thing mostly all of the
friendzone because you guys are afraid
to make the move see a lot of you were
afraid to make that move because you're
afraid that awkward moment if she says
no or you might lose their friendship
but let me tell you something
other things in this world that worth
having are worth fighting for if
sometimes you've got to take a chance
now mind you you have to be this
person's friends first to be even in the
so-called friend zone some of you fools
out there think you're in the friend
zone but you're not even that friend my
brother you in a dipper zone it's called
the twilight zone you crazy-ass mother
not alas no being really close to a
person before you get with them isn't
really necessarily a bad thing
you see if you got close enough to that
person with that person has opened up to
you as a confidant and it really allows
you to get to know their heart the hard
path is over all you gonna do is pick up
your dusty now set off the park you got
to stop being afraid and go do something
about it if she's not your friend at the
end of the day guess what [ __ ] wasn't
your good friend in the first place
you know what I'm actually gonna take
this time to go ahead and use my own
advice on this wall
I've actually been attracting this one
girl for years now and I never had the
balls to go ahead and tell her so I'm
gonna take the time to do that right now
you know honestly since I moved to LA
you know uh you and I haven't really you
know been able to go ahead and connect
like we used to but I'm gonna go ahead
and take this time to go and Trey tell
you this you know I just got to get this
off my chest Mrs Butterworth I have nice
let's do it I'll do what it's three
mcdaniel's cool in by yourself
Ethan is like this stealth nap in which
a single phrase we're seeing you were
somewhere else caught up in the rapture
duo's going at you I better watch my
back before mana
snatcher I know your head about last
night and the tribe Oh what is going on
so they throw my mouth